[Musik]
[Applaus]
die korona virus krise gab jedem von uns
die gelegenheit etwas neues zu lernen
einige haben gelernt selber brot zu
backen und sich die haare zu schneiden
andere haben endlich kapiert wie viel
papier sie eigentlich wirklich im haus
haben müssen ohne dass es zum totalen
hygiene bau kommt und die
internationalen märkte haben noch etwas
gelernt dass wir alle in hohem maße von
china abhängig sind
[Musik]
die welt braucht masken china stellt sie
her hortet sie jetzt aber als china mit
dem corona virus kämpfte behielt es alle
masken im land jetzt der andere nation
sie brauchen steigt der druck auf peking
den export wieder aufzunehmen
so sieht's aus nach jahrzehnten des
offshoring also der auslagerung der
produktion nach china stellt er
plötzlich alle welt während der epidemie
fest dass sie keine mund nase masken
bekommen was ist also passiert in einem
monat von märz auf april 2020 konnte
china seine exporte vervielfachen
die zahl der atemschutzmasken und
schutzanzügen verdoppelte sich die
masken exporte stiegen um das sechsfache
und die exporte von pcr test um das
25-fache wir sprechen von millionen
tonnen medizinische ausrüstung für den
internationalen markt bestimmt
und du fragst dich wahrscheinlich was
hat das alles zu bedeuten nun im grunde
haben wir uns zu sehr an unsere made in
china produkte gelegt denn für die
meisten unternehmen ist ist ein
automatismus geworden jedes mal wenn sie
eine neue fabrik errichten ist china die
bevorzugte wahl
wie aber ist es so weit gekommen nun zum
teil liegt es daran dass alles billiger
ist aber das ist nicht der einzige grund
china bietet auch noch andere vorteile
es hat die notwendige infrastruktur
aufgebaut und weltweit exportieren zu
können und jeder der etwas herstellen
will weiß dass er in china gute
lieferanten und andere gute hersteller
finden kann
die ihn versorgen nachdem china
jahrelang die beliebteste fabrik der
welt war sind die chinesischen arbeiter
immer besser ausgebildet anders
ausgedrückt stell dir vor du möchtest
ein elektronikunternehmen aufbauen deine
beste option ist es nach shenzen zu
gehen da gibt es alles was dein
fabrikanten herz begehrt nicht nur
billigere arbeitskräfte als in den usa
oder europa sondern einen der weltweit
größten märkte elektronische komponenten
auf diesen planeten auf denen kannst du
gehen und sagen hallo guten morgen ich
suche diese controller platine der
nächsten generation für die drohne die
ich bauen möchte wohl eh du dich
verliebst findest du einen damen oder
herren der solche platinen kiloweise
verkauft im internet findest du bilder
von leuten die auf diesen flohmarkt
gehen um mikrochips buchstäblich
tütenweise zu kaufen sowie deine man das
mit kartoffelchips macht und glaube mir
es gibt nur wenige orte auf der welt an
denen man so was tun
es ist also schon jetzt klar
china ist für die fertigungsindustrie
wie geschaffen aber wenn eine pandemie
steht man natürlich die nachteile dessen
dass man sich so sehr auf china
verlassen hat und über pandemien hinaus
müssen wir noch andere risiken in
betracht ziehen wir sprechen über
politik wie du sicher weiß hat schon
einen handelskrieg mit china gefühlt
aber denke jetzt bitte nicht zu kurz so
wie du es vom mainstream gewohnt ist
schont ist nicht der einzige der keine
geschäfte mehr mit peking machen will
lassen wir mal einen blick nach japan
[Musik]
[Applaus]
japan stellt 243 5 milliarden yen zur
verfügung um firmen bei der
produktionsverlagerung aus china so
unterstützen
wie man aktuell und sehen kann scheint
die idee der ungezügelten globalisierung
stark an schwung abzunehmen darf die der
meinung sind dass man china nicht mehr
vertrauen kann und wir die produktion
wieder auf verschiedene länder verteilen
müssen diese einst glückliche welt in
der wir alle um den globus hätten uns an
den händen hielten und wahrsagen und
grenzen ignorierten gibt es nicht mehr
die heutige frage lautet also ist dieser
trend in der welt der unternehmen
wirklich so stark denken unternehmen
daran china zu verlassen heute werden
wir diese fragen beantworten aber lasst
uns zunächst einen blick auf die
geschichte werfen
der chinesische nachfrage buch
globalisierung wurde erstmals in den
1990 er jahren zu einem richtigen
schlagwort und es wurde nicht immer
wohlwollend darüber gesprochen denn
diejenigen unter euch die mehr oder
weniger in meinem alter sind werden sich
sicher an die bewegungen der
globalisierungsgegner erinnern gruppen
wie attac zum beispiel diese
organisierte große proteste in seattle
brach hamburg de noir und vielen anderen
städten rund um den globus es war eine
ironische weise globale bewegung aber
warum haben sie alle gegen die
globalisierung protestiert nun es wäre
wohl einfacher zu erklären weswegen sie
nicht protestiert haben gut aber
verkürzt kann man sagen dass diese leute
dachten die globalisierung diene allein
den interessen der usa dass der rest der
welt lediglich rohstoffe und billige
arbeitskräfte zur verfügung stellen
würde die dann von multinationalen
konzernen ausgebeutet werden
die globalisierung ist selbst ein
codewort eine maske um nicht das k wort
kapitalismus zu benutzen
sie ist ein system das herzstück dieses
systems in die vereinigten staaten von
amerika das einzige heute existierende
imperium der welt tariq ali british
pakistanischer intellektueller auf diese
weise würden die vereinigten staaten
noch alter werden indem sie ihre
produkte und ihre kultur in die ganze
welt exportieren die würden an einen
punkt gelangen an denen die menschen
ihre identität an einem perfiden
kapitalismus verlieren würden und wo
sich früher kebab gegessen haben würden
sie mit der globalisierung dazu
übergehen nur noch weg max zu essen was
er jedoch in den letzten jahren gesehen
haben ist etwas ganz anderes ja die
wirtschaft der vereinigten staaten ist
weiter gewachsen und hat ein anderes
gewicht in der weltwirtschaft aber sie
ist immer weniger dominant damit du dir
eine vorstellung davon machen kannst in
den nutzern oder 80er jahren ein ziel
auf die usa etwa 25 prozent des globalen
bruttoinlandsprodukts jetzt im jahr 2020
erreichen sich nicht mal mehr 20 prozent
und das ist eine gute nachricht denn das
bedeutet dass auch der rest der welt
wächst und zwar schneller als die usa
tatsächlich kann man sagen dass das
wichtigste symbol der globalisierung
kebab ist die typische mahlzeit in der
orientalischen welt in den 70er jahren
wurde zb kaum jemand in europa was döner
kebab ist und heute zielt ist neben
pizza hamburgern und sushi zu den ganz
normalen speise gewohnheiten des otto
normal europäer wenn die schottische
franchise firma german döner kebab nicht
der inbegriff der globalisierung ist
dann sich auch nicht mehr aus
die firma german döner kebab aus glasgow
verkauft kebabs im wert von einer
million pfund pro woche ihre preis der
eigentümer von german döner kebab hat
welteroberung screen wenn wir uns jetzt
auf den wirtschaftlichen bereich
konzentrieren was ist passiert nun ja es
ist wahr die ersten unternehmen die in
china gingen wurden von billigen
arbeitskräften haben gezwungen in china
erleben zwar sehr viele leute da aber
immer mehr unternehmen ins land kamen
mussten sie immer mehr um arbeitskräfte
konkurrieren und das bedeutet dass die
löhne stiegen die sind so weit gestiegen
dass wir seit drei jahren schlagzeilen
wie diese sehen
[Musik]
das lohnniveau in china entspricht oder
übertrifft jenes in manchen teilen
europas
das ist ein trend der schon vor langer
zeit zu beobachten war apple schloss
seine letzte produktionslinie in den
vereinigten staaten im jahr 2000 irrt
ist dahin war der größte teil der
produktfertigung nach china verlagert
worden im jahr 2013 hatte apple jedoch
begonnen computer in texas erst stellen
wenn die höheren löhne in verbindung mit
höheren transportkosten aus dem
asiatischen land bedeutete dass chinas
doppel ass vorteil gegenüber den
vereinigten staaten wir so huber
und einige von euch denken jetzt
vielleicht okay die löhne in china
steigen und gleichzeitig verlassen
unternehmen das land das sie nicht nach
einer guten wirtschaftspolitik aus aber
das stimmt nicht denn mittlerweile ist
china ja auch zu einem großen markt
geworden ziel pekings ist es in china
nicht mehr noch waren für den export zu
produzieren sondern diese auch im
eigenen land zu verkaufen ein
unternehmen belegung ist es dank seines
starken absatzes auf den chinesischen
markt gelungen die traditionelle
spielzeug diese und die konkurrenz der
videospielindustrie zu überleben alles
was im westen verloren gegangen war ist
in china wieder gewonnen
im grunde ist es um einen markt von 1,4
milliarden chinesen ihr einkommen immer
weiter steigt sie verfügen also über
immer mehr geld um unsere produkte und
natürlich ist der zugang zu chinas im
markt bereits anreiz genug um fabriken
in china zu bauen und zu halten egal wie
stark die löhne der arbeitnehmer steigen
wenn auch die transportkosten sind sehr
teuer statt teilweise produkte mit einem
frachtschiff über mehrere wochen hin
transportieren zu müssen kann man all
das zeugs ja auch direkt in china
verkaufen im inland und eine menge
logistik kosten sparen schon allein aus
diesem grund sind viele fabriken dort
geblieben und die zahlen sprechen für
sich innerhalb von zehn jahren fiel der
exportanteil der gesamtproduktion chinas
von 17 auf 9 prozent china exportiert
also nur noch neun prozent der dort
hergestellten waren ins ausland die
nachfrage in china ist so stark
gestiegen dass ein unternehmen das eine
fabrik in china gründet schon allein
durch den absatz seiner produkte im
inland überlebensfähig wäre aber das ist
nicht der einzige grund in den letzten
30 jahren hat sich die technologie stark
weiter entwickelt die maschinen werden
immer besser werden automatisierungsgrad
stieg rapide und steckt immer noch und
dies sind einige branchen auf
revolutionäre weise umkrempelt
automatisierung und künstliche
intelligenz werden arbeitsintensive
fertigung in spittal intensive
beschäftigung verwandeln
was bedeutet dass es für unternehmen
immer attraktiver wird eine moderne
fabrik mit einem hochmodernen
maschinenpark zu haben anstatt eine
veraltete fabrik mit vielen arbeiter der
faktor lohn wird also bei der
entscheidung wo eine fabrik eingerichtet
wird nicht mehr so wichtig sein und an
diesem punkt ist ist für ein unternehmen
interessanter mehrere fabriken zb für
spielzeug oder für atemschutzmasken auf
regionaler ebene zu errichten dadurch
spart der logistikkosten und wenn die
arbeit in einer bestimmten region teure
ist kann er einfach den
automatisierungsgrad erhöhen billiger
arbeitskräfte sind für die
standortentscheidung einfach nicht mehr
so ausschlaggebend wie früher wenn man
über eine gute infrastruktur gute
lieferung weniger energie um hoch
qualifizierte arbeitskräfte für den
umgang mit jenen automatisierten
maschinen die letzten jahre zeigen uns
also letztlich einen sich abzeichnenden
trend die regionalisierung der
wertschöpfungskette was in asien
produziert wird wird in asien verkauft
das in amerika produziert wird in
amerika und immer mehr von dem was in
europa produziert wird bleibt dadurch
auch in europa
dieser trend hat sich natürlich durch
den von den vereinigten staaten
eingeleiteten handelskrieg beschleunigt
die auffassung dass angst das ist nicht
in ordnung ist wenn eine fabrik in china
produzierte produkte herstellt die in
den vereinigten staaten verkauft werden
sollen hat sich immer mehr durchgesetzt
und zwar weltweit auch wenn es viele
trump gegner dies nicht wahrhaben wollen
dies ging erst als langsamer trendlos
schlüssel aber mit voller wucht durch
als die korona krise kam
romano me sagte der name asl etwas es
handelt sich um ein niederländisches
unternehmen von dem du wahrscheinlich
noch nie in seinem leben gehört haben
wirst in der welt ist es jedoch
fundamental ist dominiert den markt
innovativster chip herstellung durch den
einsatz foto lithografen oder maschinen
die integrierte schaltkreise herstellen
als ml arbeitet mit den weltweit
führenden chiphersteller zusammen dem us
amerikanischen unternehmen intel den
südkoreanischen samsung und dem
taiwanesischen taiwan semiconductor
diese unternehmen verwenden also alle
von essent hergestellte komponenten zur
herstellung ihrer chips tieren in
rechnern handys autos maschinen und was
weis ich verbraucht werden natürlich
befindet sich auch in deiner nähe ein
produkt das mit hilfe von asl system
hergestellt wurden und deswegen ist es
jetzt an der zeit mal über den
schmetterlingseffekt nachzudenken
höchst der flügelschlag eines
schmetterlings in brasilien einen
tornado in texas aus edward lorenz
amerikanischer mathematiker das ist
etwas worum es in der chaostheorie geht
unberechenbarkeit stell dir also vor das
reisen wegen eines unvorhergesehenen
ereignisse schließen müsste plötzlich
würden smartphone produktionslinien auf
der ganzen welt zusammenbrechen
die hersteller würden sich so lange
halten die ihre lagerbestände reichen
aber bald würden die chips extrem knapp
werden denn preise würden in die höhe
schießen und mit ihnen alle mit schiffs
bestimmten geräte wenn sie denn
überhaupt noch zu bekommen werden
findest du ich übertreibe nun etwas
ähnliches ist schon öfter passiert zb im
jahr 2012 in der automobilindustrie im
honig werk im nordrhein-westfälischen
marl kam es zu einer starken verpuffung
und einem anschließenden brand
mitarbeiter kamen dabei ums leben
honig ist der weltweit führende
lieferant eines wichtigen praxis für
bremssysteme und damals waren die folgen
dieses einen lokalen ereignisse schon
nach sehr kurzer zeit weltweit zu
spielen
brand in deutscher kleinstadt könnte
welt automobil produktion drosseln wenn
es ein konzept das wir uns in diesem
jahr zu eigen machen müssen dann ist es
das der wertschöpfungskette und der
damit zusammenhängenden lieferketten
hier sprechen vom gesamten prozess in
dem die verschiedenen unternehmen und
lieferanten möglicherweise aus mehreren
ländern an der produktion von gütern
beteiligt sind und wie wir bereits
erwähnt haben ist es war das ein problem
bei globalen lieferketten darin besteht
dass sie wahrscheinlich keine zu 100
prozent echte globalisierung erreicht
haben wenn wir überlegen was dieser
begriff wirklich bedeuten sollte denn
wenn wir vorne globalisierung sprechen
dann meinen wir in wirklichkeit die
vereinigten staaten europa und china die
miteinander handel treiben wir können
noch japan und die asiatischen tiger
vielleicht nur russland dazu zählen und
das war's dann auch schon
vielleicht möchtest du noch ein paar
andere asiatische länder wie malaysia
oder indonesien einbeziehen aber deren
zahl und bedeutung ist schon ziemlich
gering indien ist dafür bekannt dass es
belege callcenter und programmierer hat
aber wir sehen bei uns selten etwas auf
dem made in india steht die quintessenz
dieses ganzen ist dass die globale
lieferkette übermäßig von china abhängig
ist und zwar auf einem niveau dass du
dir nicht vorstellen kannst so stammen
beispielsweise 95 prozent des in den
vereinigten staaten konsumierten
schwärzesten gute szene aus jeder
rona virus könnte weltweit von
medikamenten parkett führen da chinas
fabrikschließungen die lieferketten
treffen diese abhängigkeit von china ist
problematisch denn die lieferkette wird
zufällig eine maßnahme wie james
einführung von zöllen auf chinesischen
stahl wird viele unternehmen in den ruin
treiben da sie sich die höheren
stahlpreise nicht mehr leisten können
und einfach nicht mehr wettbewerbsfähig
sind aus den sind dies peanuts gegenüber
dem was sich in der korona krise
abspielt über nacht wurde in china unter
quarantäne gestellt und das bedeutete
die vorübergehende schließung vieler
fabriken angehalten damit zu kämpfen
weil sie an das produktions und logistik
know how chinas gehört waren die gute
arbeit die chinesen ermöglichte es
vielen ausländischen herstellern auf
grundlage der just in time philosophie
zu arbeiten und dadurch ihre kosten
massiv zu senken
just in time versucht die lagerbestände
auf ein minimum zu reduzieren indem alle
eingehenden komponenten rohstoffe nach
ihrem eintreffen sofort
weiterverarbeitet und an die kunden
ausgeliefert werden welche sie ebenfalls
ohne große lagerhaltung an den endkunden
absetzen können denn ein großes lager
ist ein sehr kostspieliges vergnügen
nicht nur das gebäude und der
verwaltungsaufwand schlagen zu buche
denn auch der kapitaleinsatz für die
ganzen eingelagerten produkte deswegen
hat das just in time konzept das ziel
die exakte menge an produkten zur
richtigen zeit am richtigen ort zur
verfügung zu haben
die kehrseite davon ist dass dadurch
natürlich jede verbringt die wochenlang
still steht ernsthafte probleme in der
lieferkette verursachen kann
die korona virus krise hat aber auch
gezeigt welche unternehmen die
chinesische abriegelung am besten
überstanden haben einige unternehmen
haben versucht die schließung durch eine
steigerung der produktion in ihren
anderen fabriken in ländern wie vietnam
auszugleichen
apple hat die herstellung eigener
airports pro von china nach vietnam
verlegt
wie du sehen kannst haben einige dank
ihrer fabriken in vietnam
trotz der chinesischen abbringen und
weiter produziert so konnten sie ihren
konkurrenten den rang ablaufen in der
geschäftswelt haben dies ziele zur
kenntnis genommen analysiert und sind zu
einem eindeutigen ergebnis gelangt dem
konzept china + 1 das heißt man behält
seine fabriken in china und produziert
dort waren um diese an die 1,4
milliarden chinesischen verbraucher zu
verkaufen
gleichzeitig versuchen aber auch sich in
anderen ländern anzusiedeln um sich vor
unvorhergesehenen ereignissen zu
schützen deshalb verlassen unternehmen
china nicht vollständig sie
diversifizieren einfach mit fabriken an
anderen standorten welche auswirkungen
hat dies auf die globalisierung
schauen wir uns das mal etwas genauer
echte globalisierung
wir können sagen dass die globalisierung
10 begann als die vereinigten staaten
den marshall-plan auf den weg brachten
westeuropa war durch die zerstörungen im
zweiten weltkrieg stark geschwächt
worden indem sie europa aus dem loch
halfen bekamen die vereinigten staaten
einen topf handelspartner und so ist es
bis heute geblieben mit der einbindung
vorteil ist asiens gesamte
globalisierung 2 0 das war der zeitpunkt
als japan und die asiatische tigermücke
an den weltmarkt mit ihren produkten zu
finden das war die zeit in der ich noch
als kleiner rotzlöffel mit
taschenrechner herum lief damals war
alles made in taiwan oder made in japan
aber diese länder waren nicht nur
produzenten sondern auch wichtige
kontakte die globalisierung 30 ist das
was wir in den letzten jahren erlebt
haben diese verschiebung hin zum handel
mit china
der moment in dem china zur fabrik der
welt wurde und sich entwickelt hat um
waren für die eigene große nachfrage zu
produzieren der nächste schritt in der
globalisierung wäre die expansion in
andere länder und es werden bereits
schritte dazu unternommen wie zum
beispiel apples schritt nach aber solche
dinge sind eigentlich nicht mehr
außergewöhnlichen liegen voll im trend
sie den mann an was die taiwanesische
firma hay besser bekannt unter ihrem
handelsnamen foxconn der haupt
auftragsfertiger des eises unternimmt -
von ihren zwölf fabriken in china
ausgewirkt
[Musik]
hon hai weitet fertigung in indien
ausgeht nahm inmitten von
handelsspannungen
aber dieses thema geht über
handelskriege oder die krone krise
hinaus china wird in dieser neuen phase
der globalisierung eine führende rolle
spielen in dieser ausdehnen oder
globalisierung auf andere länder gibt
dessen ende die bereits zu chinas china
werden das heißt standorte eine welche
chinesische unternehmen ihre produktion
auslagern das wird china veranlassen
seine handelsbeziehungen mit anderen
ländern auszubauen und diese werden
ebenfalls wohl diese situation
profitieren
wir sprechen von vietnam kambodscha laos
waren der dash und den philippinen aber
auch andere länder die wahl von peking
entfernten china verwandelt äthiopien in
eine riesige fast fashion patrick und es
geht nicht nur darum dass chinesische
unternehmen neue standort dass sie ihre
ansiedlung der fabriken finden sie
fördern auch unternehmen in anderen
ländern zu investieren damit china dann
marschieren an sie verkaufen kann eine
strategie welche deutschland viele jahre
erfolgreich gefahr ist und china findet
auch neue märkte für firmen die im
eigenen land spielen konkurrenz haben
dies ist der fall beim
smartphone-hersteller trends der größte
telefonverkäufer in afrika ist ein wenig
bekanntes chinesisches unternehmen
sie beginnen dieses videos haben wir
euch davon erzählt dass politiker wie
trump oder ag unternehmen dazu drängen
china zu verlassen und was passiert
jetzt
es sieht so aus dass einige vielleicht
wirklich gehen aber alles deutet eher
darauf hin dass die mehrheit darauf
setzt in china zu bleiben und sich für
einen china + 1 strategie zu entscheiden
es scheint also dass die korona krise
die weltwirtschaft nicht zu eindeutig
verändern wird wie es alle erwartet
haben wieder mal wird es kein schwarz
und weiß geben sondern eine komplexe
entwicklung echte globalisierung
regionalisierung der
wertschöpfungsketten und die china + 1
stadt ergibt dass der details die er zu
beobachten sind als das ende der
globalisierung so und nun kommt die
preisfrage an euch glaubt irrt ist diese
neue phase der globalisierung alle
afrikaner zu bringen wird nudeln zu
essen
glaubt ihr dass lateinamerika vor allem
großen buch steht und was noch wichtiger
ist was gibt es heute abend zu essen
bürger lieber pizza oder sushi
wir hoffen dass wir dieses video etwas
gebracht hat falls ja gebt uns bitte
auch einen daumen hoch und unterstütze
uns in den usa mit einem freund
da ist vergisst bitte auch nicht dass
wir jede woche neue frische videos
hochladen also verpasst keines unserer
updates abonniere unseren kanal klick
auf das klingeln symbol um rechtzeitig
benachrichtigt zu werden
macht's gut und bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]